Los modelos de programación son especificaciones fundamentales que definen
cómo se estructura el software
y cómo se ejecuta; proporcionan un marco
para que los desarrolladores expresen algoritmos
y organicen el código, abstrayendo los detalles de bajo nivel
del hardware subyacente o del entorno de ejecución.
Distintos modelos son adecuados para distintos tipos de problemas
y arquitecturas de hardware, y ofrecen
distintos niveles de abstracción
y control. En este capítulo
repasaremos los modelos de programación cuántica y clásica
y veremos cómo combinarlos para implementar algoritmos
híbridos.
Empezaremos con el modelo de programación
para una computadora cuántica. Un modelo de programación fundamental
que conocen casi todos los desarrolladores cuánticos
es el quantum circuit. No vamos a entrar
en los detalles de los quantum circuits
aquí, ya que contamos con muchos recursos excelentes,
entre ellos una clase de Joan Waters.
Solo mencionaremos que el circuit está compuesto por
un conjunto de líneas llamadas cables que representan qubits,
así como gates que representan operaciones sobre estados cuánticos,
y un conjunto de mediciones.
Otro concepto importante del modelo de programación
son las primitivas.
Estas primitivas representan las tareas más frecuentes
que los usuarios quieren realizar con una computadora cuántica.
Hay dos primitivas disponibles en este momento:
Sampler y Estimator. Sampler te permite
muestrear un estado preparado por un quantum circuit,
y Estimator te permite estimar el valor esperado de
un observable para un sistema en el estado preparado por tu quantum
circuit. El último concepto
del que vamos a hablar en esta sección
es la transpilación. La transpilación
es el proceso de reescribir un quantum circuit de entrada
para que se ajuste a la topología de un dispositivo cuántico
específico
para su ejecución en computadoras cuánticas con ruido.
De manera similar a los compiladores clásicos,
una rutina de transpilación transforma gradualmente
la estructura del circuit aplicando un conjunto de pasadas.
Ahora hablemos de los modelos de programación clásica.
Hay muchos modelos de programación
para computadoras clásicas,
pero en este capítulo nos centraremos en dos:
los más populares: programación paralela
y flujos de trabajo de tareas. Usando estos dos modelos
en combinación con los modelos de programación cuántica,
se puede expresar prácticamente cualquier flujo de trabajo híbrido
cuántico-clásico de cualquier complejidad.
El modelo de programación paralela
divide un programa en subproblemas que pueden ejecutarse
al mismo tiempo. Hay dos paradigmas principales de programación paralela:
paralelismo de memoria compartida y paralelismo de memoria distribuida.
Para nuestros propósitos, centrémonos en el modelo de memoria distribuida.
Un modelo de memoria distribuida
utiliza procesos independientes en núcleos separados
o nodos, donde cada proceso tiene su propia memoria
y la comunicación se realiza mediante paso de mensajes. Hay
algunos conceptos que conviene conocer.
El primero es el proceso,
que es una instancia independiente del programa
que se ejecuta en un núcleo separado.
También está el rank, que es el identificador único del proceso,
y luego está el modelo de abstracción
de programa único, datos múltiples (SPMD),
que es un modelo de abstracción
para la computación en el que una sola instancia del programa
se distribuye a múltiples nodos,
de modo que el código fuente es el mismo
pero los datos en esos nodos son distintos.
La ejecución del modelo de programación paralela
ocurre de la siguiente manera:
un único programa se distribuye a múltiples nodos
y lanza múltiples procesos en paralelo.
El flujo de control del programa está determinado por el rank,
es decir, el identificador del proceso,
y la comunicación ocurre
mediante paso de mensajes.
El modelo de programación de flujos de trabajo de tareas
abstrae la computación en un grafo o DAG,
donde cada nodo del grafo es una tarea específica
o trabajo, y las aristas son dependencias de datos
y de orden. Se pueden encontrar ejemplos en nuestra documentación.
De hecho, la secuencia de la que siempre hablamos en computación
cuántica —mapeo, optimización,
ejecución y postprocesamiento—
es un modelo de programación de flujos de trabajo de tareas
donde todas las tareas se ejecutan una detrás de
otra en el pipeline.
Pero con los flujos de trabajo de tareas
no estamos limitados a un orden de ejecución secuencial
y podemos ejecutar tareas en paralelo.
Cada tarea o flujo de trabajo puede ser un trabajo paralelo completo
por sí solo, así que puedes mezclar
y combinar estos modelos para describir algoritmos
de cualquier complejidad.
Intentemos aplicar en código algunos de los conceptos que aprendimos.
Primero intentaremos ejecutar un simple "hola mundo"
usando el paradigma de programación paralela.
Vamos a usar Open MPI,
que es una implementación del protocolo MPI,
el estándar para el paso de mensajes
en programación paralela.
Primero necesitamos tener nuestro programa listo.
Aquí usamos mpi4py,
que es el binding de Python
para MPI, y como puedes ver, usamos el rank para decidir
el flujo de control del programa.
Ahora veamos nuestro script de envío.
Como puedes ver, vamos a usar dos nodos,
una tarea por nodo en la partición normal,
y ejecutemos nuestro programa. Esperaremos un momento
y podremos revisar los resultados de nuestro trabajo.
Como puedes ver, tenemos los registros de salida de nuestro programa.
Aquí usamos dos nodos y dos procesos,
que se identifican por un rank.
Como puedes ver en la salida,
el rank cero y el rank uno se usaron para decidir
el flujo de control de nuestro programa.
Como puedes ver, el proceso de rank cero envió
una carga útil al proceso de rank uno,
y el proceso de rank uno la recibió.
También hablaremos sobre los flujos de trabajo de tareas.
Hay herramientas llamadas sistemas
de gestión de flujos de trabajo, diseñadas específicamente
para ejecutar flujos de trabajo complejos.
Pero para no sobrecargarte, vamos a usar la función integrada
de dependencias de Slurm
para construir esos grupos computacionales.
Primero necesitamos tener listas las tareas de nuestro flujo de trabajo.
Este es el mismo código.
La ventaja de tener cada una de estas tareas
—mapeo, optimización, ejecución
y postprocesamiento— como pasos separados
es que podemos especificar requisitos de recursos únicos
para cada tarea. Por ejemplo, el mapeo, la optimización
y el postprocesamiento no necesitan
acceso a recursos cuánticos,
por lo tanto podemos ejecutarlos en la partición clásica.
Pero la tarea de ejecución necesitará
recursos cuánticos, por lo que la ejecutaremos en la partición cuántica.
cuántica.
Ahora usemos la función de dependencias para encadenar las tareas
en un flujo de trabajo.
Como puedes ver, todavía se está ejecutando
nuestro script de envío con el flag --parsable,
que devolverá el ID del trabajo,
y luego podemos pasar ese ID de trabajo
como dependencia a otras tareas.
Como puedes ver, estamos ejecutando
los trabajos del flujo de trabajo con la dependencia.
Una vez completado todo el flujo de trabajo, podemos revisar los resultados.
Y como puedes ver, tenemos de vuelta nuestro valor de expectación.
Y también podemos revisar todos
los resultados de cada uno de los pasos.
Que también están aquí.
Y eso es todo para la sección de modelos de programación.
En el próximo capítulo vamos a hablar sobre algoritmos
avanzados.